[Music]
the sports card industry is having a
tech revolution and the southern
california-based company collectors
wants to lead the charge
led by 36 year old ceo and chairman nat
turner the company is updating the way
sports cards get graded an increasingly
crucial service as prices for high-end
collectibles soar into the millions
[Music]
collectors examines tens of thousands of
sports cards a day making sure they're
authentic and judging their physical
condition
the company is now starting to use
high-tech tools to speed up the process
and give customers more information
about their prized belongings
video cameras track every movement of
every card through the company's offices
and allow for gps location monitoring
there are qr codes on the card holders
and a fleet of imaging machines that
take high resolution photos of each
incoming and outgoing card
additionally computer vision software
helps researchers quickly identify each
card's year make and addition
those upgrades helped collectors secure
100 million dollars in funding in
january pushing its valuation to 4.3
billion dollars that's a five-fold
increase from a year earlier when a
group of investors took collectors
private
the company which was until recently
known as collector's universe was
created in 1999
but its history stretches back to the
1986 founding of professional coin
grading service or pcgs
and the 1991 founding a professional
sports authenticator or psa
both divisions are in the business of
verifying that collectibles are
authentic and unaltered
they also look for printing defects and
physical damage like creases assigning a
1 through 70 score for coins and a 1
through 10 score for cards
customers pay a fee from 50 to 12 000
per submitted card based on the item's
estimated value and whether it includes
an autograph
they're willing to shell out that money
because a grade from a company like psa
increases the card's value and makes it
easier to sell as counterfeiting has
become more sophisticated some buyers
won't even consider a card that hasn't
been graded it's not all that different
from gia certifications for diamonds the
goal is to provide information to level
the playing field for buyers and sellers
trading cards spent the last 20 years on
a steady upward trajectory until the
pandemic kicked into overdrive
inflation fears low interest rates and
uncertainty around the stock and bond
markets push investors towards
alternative and tangible assets
celebrities and influencers like
entrepreneur gary vaynerchuk rapper
drake and youtube star logan paul spread
the gospel on social media
new categories of collectibles including
sneakers and non-fungible tokens help to
track the younger demographic
the card market skyrocketed
[Music]
a one-of-a-kind mike trout rookie card
sold for 3.9 million dollars in august
2020 setting a record which was beaten
five months later by a 5.2 million
dollar mickey mantle and that was broken
again the following august by a 6.6
million dollar honest wagner card
ebay one of the largest marketplaces for
trading cards reported the category grew
142
in 2020 and then it sold more cards in
the first six months of 2021 than all of
2020.
the spike in demand caused cards to pile
up at collectors which wasn't equipped
to handle that kind of capacity
the backlog hit 13 million cards with
nearly a hundred thousand new cards
coming in every day
on a single day in march 2021 the
company received 660 000 cards
collectors had to rent school buses with
security guards to pick them up from the
post office ceo nat turner told us
the companies had to make a lot of
changes to catch up it now has more than
100 card graders up from 44 in early
2021 and a new internal training program
called grading you helping it find new
grading talent
in all the company expects to add 680
positions this year taking its total
headcount to nearly 2 000
collectors is also adding card grading
centers in new jersey and in tokyo
meanwhile the company's tech and product
teams have been building a software
platform they call card manager
aiming to use artificial intelligence to
supplement the humans in the grading
assembly line quickly identifying cards
pulling up comparison images and running
diagnostics the software should even be
able to fingerprint the cards by looking
at unique anomalies on the surface which
will help detect alterations
at the same time collectors is expanding
into new categories it acquired the
auction house golden last year as well
as wada which provides a grading service
for video games and it's building a
vault in delaware where for a fee it
will store high value cards on behalf of
customers
the company still faces challenges the
continuing avalanche of demand has
prevented psa from reopening its
cheapest tiers and it's been rationing
submissions through a lottery system at
the 50 per card level
counterfeiters are getting better at
making fake cards and competition from
other grading companies is getting more
intense
the biggest risk is future demand wild
price accelerations have naturally
raised worries that this is a bubble and
prices have slowly crept down since last
year
but many in the industry brush off those
concerns for starters venture capital
money is pouring into the space and
startups are bringing innovative new
services to card collecting
the team at collectors certainly sees
big things ahead even if it means
fundamentally rethinking a century-old
industry
[Music]
you